c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli ajouté gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche cassera da sera parce que
c'est un kiff
mais ça s'est arrêté je sais partir de
métro vient d'un village mon tissu dans
la palme et roscoe départ ça sera trop
stress ici par rapport au sud mais
supérieure il passera sa part et voir
inscrit comme celui matin but c'est
drôle il ya beaucoup ils partent chacun
coupe du monde tu es drôle
c'est l'instant incertain sera le poil
sirugue c'est dégueulasse c'est
d'astreinte parce que des fois ça fait
du bien si on sent mieux grâce à la
chirurgie c'est là
[Musique]